hand hygiene is very interesting because
it really involves trying to change
behavior because when I first study hand
hygiene I was looking at the
microbiology what germs grow on your
hands what soaps work the best and what
I learned after a period of years is
that it doesn't really matter if you
even had the perfect soap if nobody uses
it then it's not gonna make a difference
so my interest sort of changed over
years from sort of more of a micro
biologic emphasis to how do we change
behavior it's been a very stubborn
problem and whether it has to do with
washing or cleaning your hands putting
on a gown to prevent transmission
infection or whatever there have been
major efforts now to change not just
individual behavior but the systems in
which people work to make it easy to do
the right thing people are often advised
to sing happy birthday when they wash
their hands but you could sing happy
birthday 20 times and be washing your
hands and yet still wouldn't work you'd
be doing it wrong because if you look at
the way people often wash their hands
they rub their palms together but it's
the fingertips that are actually
touching people and touching other
things so when you wash the hands the
main thing is not the time but just to
make sure that you get all the surfaces
between and particularly around the nail
beds because we have found that the nail
beds is where a lot of the germs grow in
terms of hand sanitizers the waterless
products the nice thing is you don't
have to worry about a sink you can have
the hand sanitizer in your pocket or
whatever the trick with that is that you
need enough quantity and we've done some
studies to show that if you use like oh
maybe a fourth of a teaspoon it's not
enough you need to use enough so that
you can actually rub it in with your
fingernails like this and then rub like
that
and the alcohol works as long as it's
wet so you have to put enough on so that
it doesn't immediately dry when you put
it on it only works when it's wet and it
kills very quickly we used to think that
about 30% of healthcare-associated
infections were
preventible now we think it's probably
more like 70% so let's say that I am
working with you and you're my patient
and I don't wash my hands
the chances that you're going to get
infection are pretty low but if you have
open wound if your immune system is weak
that kind of thing you will will likely
get an infection so the the problem is
sorting out in this multifactorial
causal picture how much of it is
actually caused from hand hygiene but we
do know from all the work that's been
done that probably about 20 to 30
percent reduction could be possible in
certain kinds of infections if people
did hand hygiene the way they're
supposed to